[Music]
it's often either/or or both but I would
say that one of the very disturbing
trends of the last two or three decades
is the decline of the principle of
universal human rights and the rise of
what's been called cultural relativism
so the idea that in other cultures
because of politics or religion people
should be left to suffer because it's
their culture so we often hear about the
plight of women in Iran that you know
Iran is a sovereign state you know Iran
is a state based on Shia Islam curious
land has certain rules about women
therefore we shouldn't interfere we
shouldn't get involved now I don't
believe in interference but it does
shock me that every year usually fifty
to a hundred very courageous Iranian
women rarely on International Women's
Day outside just a square in Tehran get
beaten and arrested by the police and
Western leftists and feminists do not
rally to their support I find that
shameful you know a few years ago in one
single night 800 Iranian trade unionists
were arrested by the regime sent to
prison and tortured and we didn't hear a
squeak out of the Labor Party or
left-wing groups or the trade union
movement or most of the trade union
movement in this country so I think this
concept of universal rights is not
firmly established and has been greatly
under assault in in recent times I mean
there's a question there of you that
very eloquently but of course sometimes
the kind of thing you're protesting
against is in the name of a kind of a
relativism it's put it more positively
perhaps some people argue that you know
we have to be on our guard constantly
about a kind of a moral imperialism the
imposing of values and a lot of people
would say that some liberal
interventionism the kind of thing that
has got a bad name since the Iraq war is
the example of actually what happens
when you
when you just don't treat the whole
world as though there were no
distinction between the citizens of your
country and the citizens of another
actually it's a kind of a recipe for for
disaster a lot of the time do you see
the very force in our yeah well I don't
believe in the imposition of Western
values or Western intervention but I do
believe in supporting the many people in
those countries who are struggling for
those freedoms so I support the Iranian
trade unionists the Iranian women's
movement the persecuted Kurds beluche
and Arab peoples of Iran I support their
struggle so it's about solidarity with
their fight not about me seeking to
impose my values on them
you